paving your own path us leaved by me
create your own path take your own path
finding your own path what's that
believe nation it's evan my one word is
believe i believe in you and i want to
see that special thing you've got inside
you unleashed onto the world instead of
help you in your journey today we're
going to learn how you can pave your own
path to success and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below put
quotes around it so others can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy now if you're an artist or
a filmmaker or content creator in
general do you feel like you shouldn't
even go mainstream towards TV or towards
film or towards working with a music
label or should you focus on creating it
all yourself because it it still helps a
lot of people who don't know how to do
the online so yeah I mean look there's
there's no answer to that question I
think that it's one thing that everybody
but the successful people fail to
realize about any creative industry is
that there is absolutely no defined path
there isn't one so it's about paving
your own path and now for me my path
meant mainstream just didn't work and
new media did work and for other people
it's entirely antithetical to that world
where mainstream is exactly the right
place for them so there is no formula
that's that's right or wrong I'm just
much better versed in my own sure the
trajectory that I found myself and that
includes really running away from the
establishment into whatever the most
forward-thinking space is I want you all
to stay true to the most real most
sincere most authentic parts of
yourselves I want you to ask those basic
questions who do you want to be what
inspires you how do you want to give
back and then I want you to take a deep
breath
and trust yourselves to chart your own
course and make your mark on the world
maybe it feels like you're supposed to
go to law school but what you really
want to do is teach little kids maybe
your parents are expecting you to come
back home after you graduate but you're
feeling a pull to travel the world I
want you to listen to those thoughts I
want you to act with both your mind but
also your heart and no matter what path
you choose I want you to make sure it's
you choosing it and not someone else but
see what is the choice that you walk a
path like everyone else dressed in suits
go to work and come back and never have
a legacy or you swim upstream like a
trout against norm and then whatever
little you achieve is only yours it's
not like everyone else and I'd rather
have something that is my path paved by
me something that is my legacy my own
self my own achievement than being one
of the many successful people in the
world as a kid I was just mad about the
original King Kong I loved all the stop
frame animation Ray Harryhausen pictures
and hard fantasy you know I loved all
the black-and-white Universal films I
still do when I realized I think I saw a
documentary on the Disneyland show which
it was called then where you saw
Clarence Nash recording the voice of
Donald Duck I don't know if I was 6-7
but it suddenly occurred to me these
things don't just emerge full-blown
somebody goes to work and actually makes
a Daffy Duck cartoon and I thought I
want to do that I mean I wasn't sure I
wanted to be an actor I thought I could
I didn't know what I wanted to be but I
certainly wanted to be in the business
of going to work and having a colossal
ape carry a woman up the Empire State
Building I thought I you know it was
just mind-boggling to me you know that
that somebody got to do that for
through their profession I think too
many people are trying to live someone
else's path you're trying to follow your
parents path you're trying to be the
next Michael Jordan or the next wing
Gretzky or the next Steve Jobs you're
trying to be the next somebody else
where if your goal is to be the next
somebody else you're always gonna fall
short you can't out Steve Steve it's not
happening it's not gonna be possible so
you will always fall short if you are
trying to follow somebody else's path
the key is to create your own unique
path that's where you're gonna stand out
and that's where the magic is gonna
happen
you already are unique you already are
the first and only version of you that
will ever walk this planet
that has already happened but you're not
the best you yet you're the unique you
you're the first you but you're not the
best you yet and that's where you can
pull from people you can pull from jobs
you can pull from updates and you can
pull from Winfrey and you can pull from
LeBron you can pull from all these
people to make you the best version of
you and help you go off on your path and
it starts by understanding what your one
word is living your life on purpose
knowing what your values are and having
the self-awareness to create something
that is important and then by embracing
the genius of the end we're the unique
talents that you have it matched up
together in a way that nobody else can
execute on and it often counts why I
want to do this or I want to do this or
I want to do this and you've got two or
three or four things that you don't know
which direction to take and the real
answer is to smash all of those things
together because that's the unique thing
that only you can do anybody can be a
banker anybody can be a salsa dancer
anybody can be a gamer anybody can be a
fill in the blank but when you start
combining those things together and then
combine it with your one word which is
your value system that's something that
nobody else can do is something nobody
else can touch now you're off creating
your own path and being the best version
of you and that's where your ultimate
success happiness wealth and impact will
come create your own path I'm a writer
so I'm kind of curious what type of
scripts do you get coming your way that
you're tired of originality I know
that's a very but without it being aware
that it's a
being original a lot of scripts are
trying to be very original and it
they're so self-aware I think we're
living nowadays in a meta society and we
can't help ourselves than that and I
think a lot of manifest Lutton and
scripts that I read mm-hmm like they're
Charlie kept Kaufman for example he came
into this world and he wrote those
movies and since Charlie people have
tried to be like Charlie's movies you
know they've sort of followed try to
follow that form but it's not their own
it's Charlie's and so sort of follow
your own take your own path right what's
true to you and no one else and then
it'll be wholly original that's what I
look for so what inspired you to be an
actor in the first place um lack of
options and laziness no no it was a I
didn't really know what I was gonna do
and I was 17 and I was at school and
then this guy that was a former pupil at
the school had went to drama school he
came back and he just started doing
these workshops mm-hmm and I just went
to them and I just really sort of got
hooked after that I realized then that
that's what I was gonna sort of go on to
do do you like the disappearing or do
you like the play or what's the you know
I don't know I think I just sort of felt
like it was something that felt right
and comfortable in the way that I sort
of could express myself you know
creatively mm-hmm I really wanted to
sort of be a guitar or lead guitar
player and like a heavy metal band
you know was 15 and I really sort of
went at that all guns blazing for a
couple of years and then I realized it
just didn't serve him I didn't have this
sort of you know the chops for it so
then I came across acting and it just
felt really you know I felt at home
comfortable and so can you describe a
little bit your path to stand-up comedy
like how did you get involved in it oh
how I got into it
I was I what - how the hell did I get
into it I think you know what I always
liked watching it on TV but it never
seemed like something that I could do
just because nobody I knew was in
the performing arts I came from real
like blue-collared Joc kind of town so I
just always thought if I said I wanted
to do something like that I get the
usual blue-collar stuff like what do you
you know you're not funny so I kind of
kept it to myself and then I was working
in a warehouse and I ended up working
with this other guy who was in the stand
up the way I was and one night we were
watching a stand-up spotlight which was
hosted by an unknown Rosie O'Donnell at
that point yeah I was on vh1 this was
like the 80s and everybody pulled their
sleeves up with it on their sport coat
and no I think she was going down on
people at that point women yeah oh yeah
kind of born that way I think she was
probably experimenting at that point but
that's another story so yeah we were
just watching it and my buddy was siscon
bill these guys suck they're not funny
where we're funnier than these guys out
we you know we should try it and then
all of a sudden it wasn't on TV was
sitting next to me and then fortunately
my college had a talent contest and I
signed up before I chickened out and I
went on stage and I only did okay I
didn't win the contest but it was just
something like I kind of sucked at
everything else at that point you know
math reading anything to do with
academics I just stunk at it core
classes yeah but joking around and
making an ass out of myself was
something that uh it was easy for me so
I did it grow up near Melbourne
Australia in an Aboriginal community huh
did you I grew up in Melbourne and then
moved to building territory in
Aboriginal community buffalo and
crocodiles in it was a rather unusual
you know childhood compared to the rest
of you and your parents of work move you
there yeah my parents worked on a cattle
station with my auntie and uncle and so
we as kids went up and just well this
has been fun as a kid it was great yeah
yeah introduction to life and it was as
vivid and as exciting as it could have
been how does somebody start a career
like like what you've accomplished in
the community like that you know we were
back and forth we didn't live there the
whole time but I think part of living
there
you know sparked some you know
imagination and then my dad read you
know many books to us as kids and
always had a love for storytelling in
films and fantasy and I think that was
the beginning of it all and then it
wasn't until I finished school I thought
this looks like fun I can do this maybe
as a career and so you started acting in
Australia yeah I tried to I'd spent a
few years on building sites and
horticultural library and you know sure
allowed me to take a day off the funny
to JJ Abrams saw you as a part of Star
Trek yeah I brought you over he did yet
while I was I was in America at the time
and just got a little independent film
and came back and I met with JJ I was on
a Friday night in his office across his
desk and he said we read the same he
said that's great you start on Monday
and I was just like that's all she's
been apprised finding your own path is
not for the faint of heart it's the
harder path it's easier to just like
keep doing the same over and over again
and then be surprised to win like it's
still the same same same results somehow
that's easier than just doing something
different I mean I never feel like I'm
like not where I'm supposed to be you
know because I think no matter who I'm
with I'm always still doing my own thing
like I can't remember the last time I
was like in a club or somewhere and felt
like man I'm not supposed to be here and
same with you know or like being in a
theater or like you know we saw saw Pink
Floyd the other day so I mean I just and
I've kind of been doing it for so long I
feel like everybody I'm friends with
everyone I know just knows I'm I'm just
all about the music thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd
love to know what did you take from this
video what was a single most important
message that you are going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business leave it down the
comments below I look forward to hearing
what you have to say I also want to give
a quick China to Justin Morgan aka new
future bill there Justin thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and doing the review on
your YouTube channel
I really really appreciate your support
man and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book Evan Carmichael thank you and
waiting for this wonderful wildness
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever
your one word is much love I'll see you
soon yeah
the most important work ever if you have
to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]